in attack on titan we can argue for days
over you know who's the bad guy
what's aaron's big master plan what's
the end game
but i'm not seeing enough people
discussing the real issue
the conversation that really needs to be
talked about
who is the best attack on titan waifu
you might be thinking is this really
important is this what we should be
talking about when aaron came in last
episode looking like this
are the waifus the waifus who we should
be talking about
and i think that this look right here
this is exactly why we have to
talk about the waifus we can't keep
letting aaron get the spotlight guys
and look look scholars as old as time
itself
have claimed to be gossip to be the one
true best girl
but take a look around you we've moved
past that
we've evolved and while there are many
candidates there is only one right
answer for the best waifu in attack on
titan
it's pick finger the kart titan and let
me tell you why
i just want you guys to know everything
in this video is just memes please do
not take me too seriously
sorry guys but y'all trying to compete
with this
reason number one that pick is the best
two words
quadrupedal advantage unlike any of
those two-legged waifus you might enjoy
only one of them has the full
functionality of all four limbs as legs
and if you don't understand why this is
important to my heart
just watch this scene
shall i play it again stop it get some
help
reason number two best mobility imagine
relying on omnidirectional mobility gear
to get around
like come on the amount of work you
gotta do sure
mikasa makes it look easy but is
anything easier than just
walking around the cart titan beats
anyone here in a foot race especially in
like a field with nothing to grapple
onto
why would being the fastest make her
better well let me tell you
do you guys remember like in fifth grade
in elementary school during recess
when the coolest person in class was
determined by who could run the fastest
yup exactly piek is the coolest girl in
class i'm sorry i didn't make the rules
reason number three she's exotic look at
all the other possible waifus
they're all survey corps members mikasa
sasha rest in peace
historia ymir annie they're all a bunch
of nerds who've been studying how to
kill titans the past like 10 years
but she's from marley she's explored the
world
befriended both races of aldians and
marlene's
she's a change of pace when you're
looking at all these people wearing
their survey core suits
granted these new like latex ones are
pretty dope but
uh come on
okay so now let's see why other waifu's
qualifications just
aren't enough to beat out piek first
historia
she's royalty she's got that money in
the bank control over
an entire island blood that can control
the founder's titan
she's a tough girl to be not gonna lie
but let's look at that closer
she's stuck being the queen of the
island she won't have time for you
she's got like thousands of people to
manage i mean look where is she right
now
she wasn't there for aaron at marley so
she won't be there for you either
accept it second sasha
well i mean she's dead so let's just say
she missed her shot
gabby didn't though wait dude
not cool too soon third ymir
also dead but to be fair she had that
whole mean girl vibe going on for her
but she was too whipped for historia
you'd never be the first in her mind
i mean how are you gonna compete with a
literal queen
fourth annie kind of unapproachable no
i mean even before she was in a massive
crystal of hardened titan flesh which
literally makes her unapproachable
she was kind of hard to look straight in
the eye i mean she's also a traitor
so turn around for a second and the next
thing you know she's like getting with
this guy
she ain't loyal i mean can you blame her
though like
damn season four bringing dudes into
this scene as well like
elena no bruh elena
all my homies hate elena get gaby in
there too all my homies hate her as well
i mean gabby doesn't qualify as a waifu
since she's a kid and all but
gabby too just need to get out my daily
dose of gabby hate i
i feel a lot better now now
lastly mikasa the lightweight champion
the one who's got piac low key running
for her money
mikasa has the advantage of being the
childhood friend this
is always a perk since she's a character
we've seen grow and we've stood witness
to all of her moments both weak
and strong cute little scenes like when
she gets the scarf wrapped around her in
crazy parts where she tries to kill
reiner and bertholdt
but there's a few reasons i think mikasa
loses here
first and foremost she's too whipped for
aaron it's the same case as with ymir
and kind of annie you know
all my boys before valentine's day we
looking for singles available in our
area
not taking chicks all my real fans know
this girl too
rip kiss anime i miss you um and second
reason
i mean she's a little crazy a bit too
much for my liking like if she snaps on
you
who's gonna stop her you you're gonna
try and stop this no
man you're done for if you get in a
fight and
lastly hear me out on this one cause
it's kind of a stretch but not really if
they think about it
mikasa is so good with her
omnidirectional gear that she almost
doesn't need
legs it's the complete opposite of pieck
who's got four of them
and i mean if you got no legs you might
as well be in a wheelchair you see what
i'm saying
i honestly don't even know what i'm
saying at this point but more is better
four legs is better than one case in
point
so for all my px stands all my fans have
refined tastes good on you
if you prefer someone else that's okay
but i hope after this video
you know who's really on top of the
waifu food chain
and i know this is really different from
my normal videos but it's really fun to
make content like this so make sure to
like and comment if you want more meme
type stuff like this
as always this has been the anime
culture corner don't forget to like and
subscribe for future in-depth show
manga and character analyses